Brent wrote in Brent said most of us
have heard of questions that aren't
legal to ask in job interviews but once
these questions are asked
aren't you basically saying don't give
me the job if you point out that the
questions are illegal how can this be
handled this is a really good question
in job interviews in the u.s. potential
employers aren't allowed to say for
example do you plan on getting pregnant
in the future as a basis to potentially
disqualify a female candidate for a job
on the mase basis that she may be out on
maternity leave for example or you're
not allowed to ask are you married maybe
to try to figure out I don't know
whether the person is going to be
distracted from work by their marriage
or might be taking the family health
insurance instead of the single which is
more expensive we can all imagine these
sort of questions obviously it would be
illegal to say hey you look like you're
of a unique ethnic background
are your parents black of course that
would not be legal to asking it in a job
interview there's all these sorts of
questions okay fair enough if an
employer if a potential employer asks
you these questions if you say it's
illegal for you to ask me that you're of
course right but you're probably going
to be disqualified from that the running
for that position because the employer
will see you as sort of difficult and
how do you prove it anyway the employer
can say no they weren't hired because
their skills weren't a match it is very
very difficult to legislate this type of
sort of employment discrimination law
can be very very tough and expensive for
the plaintiff I don't know that I have
an answer for the best way to handle it
I think if anything and this would not
work in any case I would sort of try to
answer the question with a question to
see if you can ascertain what the
concern really is right and this you can
find a lot about doing this so you might
say to me Lois as the potential employer
are you planning on having kids anytime
soon
and if I was a woman or a man really
because men can take paternity leave as
well as they should be able to I could
say you know I've always put job first
and whatever's going on in my personal
life I always make sure that my work is
not interrupted you're pretty
deliberately not
during the question and maybe the
employer would still see you as being
difficult but I would sort of try to go
in that direction knowing that if you
just stand up and say that's illegal
you're probably not getting the job even
if you're right
do you envision any situation where an
employer asks a question knowing that
it's illegal just to see your response
to that - to that question and to say
hoping that you'll say you know that's
an illegal question and you're not
interesting yeah so what you're
suggesting is an employer in order to
test the sort of assertiveness of the
applicant might knowingly ask an illegal
question to see if the employee stands
up for themselves and/or even knows that
those questions aren't allowed it's
interesting I think it's very very risky
because number one the employee would
have no way of knowing if they don't
mention it whether you know that it's an
illegal question and it could just cause
all sorts of chaos although it is an
interesting suggestion I think yeah
certainly there are plenty of other
strategies that that are legal any other
idea as far as what someone could do in
terms of no although I do like the idea
of answering a question with a question
or maybe I mean there's a good chance
the employer doesn't even know it's an
illegal question right yeah that could
be a problem as you know maybe maybe oh
maybe they'd be appreciative if you were
to bring that to their attention you
know you're actually not allowed to ask
that oh thank you so much I appreciate
it
you're hired it could happen right okay
it could seems what if what if the
position is next CEO of the company yeah
I mean that's something that that you
should be aware of you know I would be
really glad to talk about that at a
point in the future but you should know
that those types of questions are
actually not legal and they can really
create a problem for you if if your job
opportunities are looking good
and you have many interviews and this
isn't your number one choice yeah feel
free to bring it up and just see what
happens right yeah